Another thing to think about is what's the market size estimate?
How big is this and what's the percentage marketshare realistically you could get?
How many can you distribution channel actually sell?
If you have your own direct sales people, do the math.
How many customers can they call on it at what price?
As you start putting all this into a spread sheet
you actually start building the classic income statement balance sheet and cashflow
we haven't even had you do yet.
If you think about this, this entire conversation we've had
was how to get the basic data so you can put together a revenue model
that's based on fact rather than fiction.
You are going to start thinking about, well, if I have a direct sales force,
how much can they sell in dollars,
or if I'm using an indirect channel, what's realistic number they sell for other customers?
How much will it cost to have this distribution channel?
Hopefully in the last lecture you start thinking about the cost of you channel—
how many customer activations, how much it will cost to get customers
into my physical store or my virtual website.
Then as we talked about earlier, how much will it cost to acquire a customer?
And by the way, not only how much does my customer acquisition cost
but what's their lifetime value?
How many units will they by from each of these efforts?